it's all gone every penny
what was your plan my plan was to die
before the money ran out but i kept and
keep not dying
and here i am
the hens are clucking are they saying
i'm broke they are
what about my apartment at paris it's
just sitting empty
have you told your mother about our
engagement we're going to paris
would you describe yourself as a coward
no
when i came to paris the first time
something sent up an alert it was the
presentment
of what was to come
we're going to lie down will you come
visit us later
was she paying you ping aren't you her
gigolo
oh god no that's my mother
what is it an invitation to a party come
in
where are the others it's just us i
thought we might become friends i'm no
need of friends in my life
at the moment you're being a dick i'm
sorry
[Music]
have you heard any rumors regarding my
reputation
i heard that you were odd well i'm more
than hot
[Music]
there's a goodly part of me that wants
to set this building on fire
what do you think of that i've never
been
so hurt it's when i saw your face for
the first time
why because you were me
[Applause]
i've always been lucky i've been unlucky
but i have a sense that this will change
suddenly and permanently
i've only been lucky and i believe i
will always be
it's such a cliche isn't it someone
killing themselves after the glamour has
passed
do you know what a cliche is it's a
story
so fine that it's grown
old in its hope for retelling
you talk the talk don't you weep
i broke the mold with that one
[Applause]
means pig
[Music]